[Applause]
yes
basically liverpool's playing manchester
united their arch rival
and they're playing at old trafford
which is manchester united stadium okay
and before the game protesters came out
on the field and started going crazy and
lighting off like smoke bombs and like
yeah
protesting with big signs against the
glazer family which is an american
family that owns liver or
owns manchester united okay and
basically they're protesting for
a slew of grievances that the glazer
family has done to manchester united
as well as the whole super league
nonsense that happened so they're
protesting the ownership
yes whoa that's pretty effective to be
honest
and so they postponed the game they're
like the circumstances are uh
too uh is this common i thought that the
city
loves the team and like they love the
team but they don't like the ownership
because even when the
owners took on the team when they bought
manchester united i don't even remember
when
they did it through like this like
shitty like financial
strategy con where like basically they
took out loans against the team in order
to buy the team in the first place
so it was it was like finally yeah they
bought out this the shareholders between
2003 and 2005.
they slowly bought out the people who
owned it so they illegally got
by taking loans out against the team
it's like oh [ __ ] they bought the eiffel
tower of being like hey you want to take
a loan against the eiffel tower and they
go oh yeah oh my god
yeah so like that's the simplified
version and so they started with that
then they started losing records
after alex ferguson retires and then
just slowly slowly the
essence and the core of the team went
from amazing and
like winning the premier league to now
it being like good and competitive but
when i first heard it it just i thought
it was just like spoiled fans like man
you i always remembered hearing they
were so dominant
and now they're not and i thought they
were just mad about that yeah but having
shitty ownership
just ruins everything it just trickles
down into everything there's nothing you
can do
this is actually the only way fans can
fight back it's fascinating because if
you think
james golden fans going to msg and
saying
[ __ ] this we don't want to see the game
we don't support the team yeah
that's fire but let's do it that family
also owns the buccaneers
and they just won a super bowl yeah yeah
so they're kind of like
shut your mouth we're gonna figure it
out i think it's an easy way it's just
like americans coming in our turf for
such an iconic sports club and so
if you don't think it's an american
thing my understanding is was it
manchester united was owned by the
russian oligarch
one of them got bought by a russian
oligarch abramovich
yeah maybe i don't know what team that
is huh okay but uh but yeah this is
interesting i wonder if this keeps
happening
i'm sure it does bother you more that
it's american though because it's like
first of all you got you kind of got the
team through ill-gotten means
second of all cool y'all are great in
america but you don't know how this [ __ ]
works and then
that's in the back of your mind with
every grievance you have is you don't
understand this game and then at a
certain point it's like
all right fine you can do american
sports but you don't understand how the
[ __ ] this works
over here at all you have no clue that's
interesting about like
yeah yeah like all the american owners
are the ones that were like let's just
form super league who gives a [ __ ] and
then they're gonna be like
yo y'all don't [ __ ] get it this is
not for you they say what is it winning
cures all yeah winning cures everything
winning cures everything whatever but
losing exposes everything yeah that
makes sense so it's like if they were
winning i think everybody would be cool
with this like american owner and maybe
they did some shitty things
bringing over innovative styles from
america they have techniques that work
in the nfl that they brought here
it's brilliant yeah but the second
you're losing it's how dare you change
the culture
yeah and do you think this will start
happening with all the other teams
around the world that also have foreign
ownership
maybe so long as the foreign ownership
is [ __ ] up the culture
of the team as the fans see it as the
what as the fans see the culture of the
team if the
ownership comes in and starts
influencing the culture in a negative
way
right but they never do it in a positive
way like if saudi money buys manchester
city
and they start winning the premier
league they're not like saudi arabia
yeah our culture is losing yeah yeah
yeah i'm fine with that yeah if saudi
money brought the dallas cowboys and
started winning super bowls i'm so okay
with it
that's how badly that's about but
there's i don't know how you put that
genie back in the bottle
but if this becomes a little bit dude
because there's something that's just
good
yeah you know i can say that i'm close
enough right yeah yeah but
if it becomes like yo we don't like our
ownership we're gonna protest and
raise [ __ ] hell and cause mayhem
until they sell that's cool if you got
shitty ownership but then at a certain
point it might get to be
like we're protesting for nothing at a
certain point you know what i mean if
every team like if knicks fans are like
oh [ __ ] that storm the court whatever
bet
i get why you want to get rid of dolan
but at a certain point
i don't like this one season i'm [ __ ]
up everything sell the team it's like
you know what i mean
okay here's a question if the team is
tied to the city
and it and it leeches off the identity
of the city
is it weird to say that the owner should
have to be
from the city interesting like
you are representative of the city the
players are no longer represented in
that city i'm sure like at some point in
time in history
the majority of the players from team
probably were from
that local area and then obviously as
you know this game becomes a global game
you're going to want the best teams and
the teams the most money are going to be
able to bad but buy the best players
bubble i'm fine with it but i wonder if
you just make it
if you really like drive in the identity
of the city what the the richest person
in that city or the person that can't
afford it has to be one who owns it
yeah i wonder if that makes sense and
maybe that'd be kind of cool or maybe
they're
you can own the team but there's still
like a local board that has some
say in it the board thing is always
curious to me because
now you have these people that
potentially are appointed but they're
not pointed based on like
their investment in the game or their
merit like who is the board like and who
decides who's the board and how much
decision making power do they have and
like
if i'm the average billionaire i don't
want to board telling me what the [ __ ] i
can do yeah but it would be cool if the
richest person in the city just owned
the next which is
you know dulling and it sucks but it's
like he's i think he's a new yorker is
he not
i don't know i'm just saying like as the
cowboys i know you're saying right now
if saudi money wants to win this it'd be
great but you know it'd be really great
if a [ __ ]
dallas native won the cowboys new yorker
owns the knicks
fire right yeah i guess donald trump was
something cool about that
i guess dolan would be a new yorker but
then he wouldn't have been able to buy
in the first place
would that be a weird would that be a
shitty requirement i guess because
now it's suddenly not a private thing
anymore now it belongs to the citizens
of the
and is that just what happens if a team
gets big enough if a support gets
popular enough
like now it's suddenly not private now
you belong to the citizens and the price
of the teams would go way down it would
plummet yeah
because there's so few people kill the
free market too you would destroy the
free market i mean there's no way the
team would actually go with it
yeah but yeah there is something
interesting he was born in massapequa
massive peak of long island yeah wow i
don't know if you grew up there but
that's like where his parents are
it's usually like if there's that their
business is within that city like
juventus is
probably owned by like the the elkin
family that are part of fiat
and ferrari but then like milan just won
or inter milan just won
syria yesterday chinese owner zhang
came in perelli owns 0.37 percent
potential point if you're winning hey
that's great they're not complaining but
if you're losing then [ __ ] that
i don't want china on the knicks no i
agree [ __ ] that even if they won
every year they won i wouldn't want
great britain on the knicks
i won't want any other country on the
knicks i mean that sincerely
i would be upset so you're okay with
american owners not owning
soccer teams internationally yeah i'm
fine and i'm totally fine with them
being upset about it especially if it
looks like these american owners don't
give a flying [ __ ] about the sport they
just want to make money
if i were you guys i'd say [ __ ] you get
the [ __ ] out of here
i'm in favor of the protest i think
we're all in agreement here i thought
they were just spoiled
you